Though Western beauty standards may be taking the world by storm, they still aren't the norm everywhere.
There are some cultures that take their beauty standards seriously, and sometimes it can seem a bit brutal.
If you are a first time viewer, click that red "Subscribe" button.
Prepare to be shocked with these 10 unusual women beauty standards around the world.
Double Tooth, Japan.
Most of the time when people have crooked teeth in western cultures, they pay thousands of dollars
to get them fixed. The exact opposite is true in Japan where women pay to have their teeth crooked.
This beauty standard is known as "Yaeba", which translates into "double tooth" in Japanese.
The trend started with Japanese pop stars, but women with crooked teeth had been thought to be alluring
in Japan for a while.
Long earlobes, Maasai tribes of Kenya.
The Maasai tribes of Kenya have been stretching their earlobes for centuries.
The older the person is, the longer their earlobes tend to be.
The Maasai women stretch their earlobes over time with various size horns, rocks, or sticks.
Once they are done with the stretching process, they decorate their earlobes with beading ornaments.
Stretched Lips, Southern Ethiopia.
When a girl is becoming a woman in the Southern Ethiopian tribe,
they will start the lip stretching, or lip plating process.
Over a period of time she and her family will keep stretching her lip until it is about 8 to 20 centimeters
in diameter. At that point, the woman will put a plate in her lip, which she takes great pride in decorating.
The process is also important, as it is a part of wedding rituals in their culture.
Elongated Necks, Thailand.
From the time they were four years old, the women of the Kayan tribe in Northern Thailand start putting
brass coils around their neck. As the woman ages, she gets more and more coils.
Eventually, the coils elongate their neck, which is considered beautiful in their culture.
Though it seems like they are growing long necks, it's actually the weight of the coils pushing
their shoulders down that gives the illusion of the desirable long necks.
Fat Farms, Mauritania.
In the Western cultured world, it's hard to believe that people would actually send their young daughter
to fat farms to pump them up. That is exactly what they do in Maurtinia where being curvy and having
stretch marks are most desirable.
Girls are sent to camps where they're force fed up to 16,000 calories a day, all for the sake
of being able to get married.
Red clay skin and hair, Himba people of Northern Namibia
The Himba people of Northern Hamibia slather themselves from head to toe in thick clay called
otjize. The otjize is made from ochre, fat and aromatic resin. When is applied to the hair and body
it turns everything an orange-ish red, which is supposed to symbolize blood.
To the Himba people, blood is the essence of life. While this is a beauty standard, it actually serves
a second purpose. The otjize also helps protect their skin from the sun and heat.
Scarification, Ethiopia's Karo tribe.
The ancient ritual of scarification in Ethiopia's Karo tribe seems a bit brutal, but is still practiced today.
It is a long  painful process that includes women cutting patterns into their faces and chests
with sharp objects like glass or knives.
Once the wounds are open, the women rub charcoal or gun powder into the openings,
so that the wounds will form keloids once they heal.
Over a period of time, women can add more and more scars to themselves.
They think of scars as art work and admit that the only reason that they still perform scarification
is to attract men.
Face tattoos, Maori
The Maori of the indigenous Polynesian people of New Zealand have a rich and interesting culture.
Maori men and women have been using face tattoos, or facial moko, to enhance beauty, show
social status, and show personality for centuries.
No two facial moko are alike, and women usually have a less extreme version than their
male counterparts. Maori women usually get facial moko on their chins and they believe
this defines and flatters the face, draws attention to the eyes, and can even correct facial flaws.
Surgical bandages, Iran.
When it comes to beauty standards around the world, most cultures agree that noses are important,
but none of them take it as far as women in Iran, which has now become the nose job capital of the world.
Iranian women are born with what they believe are unflattering noses. So when women are old enough,
they get them fixed. To them, wearing their surgical bandages from their nose jobs are like wearing
a bandage of honor. Women believe in fake getting nose jobs, and wear fake surgical bandages
all for the sake of being desired.
Teeth filing, Indonesia
In Indonisia, it is customary for boys and girls to go through "metatah", or teeth filing.
By the time they hit puberty, this makes the teeth look elongated and sharp, and is considered
quite beautiful in their culture. The custom is said to help the soul remove sadistic urges
like jealousy and anger. While people don't have to get it done exactly at puberty, it is a custom
that must be done before someone can get married.
What did you think of these unusual beauty standards for women around the world?
React in the comment section below, and don't forget to like this video and subscribe to "The Things".